مساء الخير قرر الرئيس الامريكي دول تم
الغاء الضربه العسكريه ضد ايران قبل
موعدها بعشر دقائق ردا على اسقاطها طائره
تجسس امريكيه في 20 يونيو 2009 وعشرين
الحقيقه التفسير اللي قدمه الرئيس
الامريكي نفسه لم يقنع احدا لا في
الولايات المتحده ولا خارجها لان وقال انه
الغى العمليه لما على من جنرالاته ان هذه
العمليه سوف تؤدي الى مقتل مائه وخمسين
ايراني واعتبر ان هذا الرقم غير متكافئ
في مقابل اسقاط طائره بدون طيار من يتابع
الموقف من بدايته يقدر يقدر بسهوله ويدرك
بسهوله من الرئيس الامريكي لم يكن راغبا
ابدا في شن اي عمليات عسكريه ضد ايران
ووصل به الامر محاوله تبرير اسقاط الطائره
الامريكيه الاول حول وقلل من اهميه الحدث
وبعدين قال ان اللي اسقط الطائره هو اكيد
شخص متهور وغير يعني عايز يقول انه ضابط
او مسؤول يعني تصرف من تلقاء نفسه او اخذ
قرار سريع لا يعبر عن الموقف الايراني
يلتمس الاعذار للايرانيين ثم قرر الغاء
العمليه اللي تابع الموقف او العلاقات
الايرانيه الامريكيه يعرف الاسباب
الحقيقيه بسهوله واشر لها في حلقه مفصله
بعنوان لماذا لا توجه امريكا ضربه عسكريه
لايران لكن بعيدا عن الاطار العام الذي
يحكم الاعتبارات العسكريه او الرد العسكري
الامريكي على ايران العمليه العسكريه
الاسباب الاخرى لا علاقه لها بتفسير
الرئيس الامريكي السبب الاول ان ان الرئيس
الامريكي ليس رب الحرب يعني هو رجل يهدد
بالحرب ولكن لا يشملها ابدا لان بيعبر عن
اتجاه
او اتجاه ان عزاء في المجتمع الامريكي ايه
المجال الاتجاه الانعزال اذا تيار في
المجتمع الامريكي ان نقول احنا زهقنا من
لاعب دور الدوله القاعده في العالم دور
رجل الشرطه في العالم
احنا نركز على مرنه وده اللي قادر يعبر
عامه بتعبير امريكا اولا دعوه بالعالم
تتدخل فقط اذا كانت الامور تمس مصالحنا
بشكل مباشر جدا وبالتالي الاتجاه العام
عند الا يتورط في حروب والامثله على ذلك
كثيره بما فيها ما حدث في سوريا في ابريل
2017 ما العالم حبس انفاسه بعد تهديده
بتوجيه ضربه ساحقه ماحقه لسوريا
ليلا في احد ايام ابريل 2017 بعمليه
محدوده جدا جدا لم يتضرر منها لا القوات
السوريه ولا الايرانيه ولا حتى وانا طبعا
القوات الروسيه
يقدم نفسه على انه اكبر خالق للوظائف في
امريكا رجل عاوز ي يقدم نفسه على اعتبار
انه مصطلح للاقتصاد الامريكي المريض
وبالتالي فكره التورط في حرب ودفع فاتوره
كبيره للحرب اه سواء ماليه او في الارواح
غير وارده الامر الثاني انه الرجل يخشى من
رد الفعل الايراني مهما كان ضعيفا رد
الفعل الايراني ده ممكن ياتي على ثلاث
مستويات المستوى الاول رد فعل مكلفه خسائر
في الارواح القوات الامريكيه الموجوده في
المنطقه وهي بعشرات الالاف او في رده فعل
الدول الحليفه للولايات المتحده خصوصا دول
الخليج والامر الثالث هو نتيجه العمليات
العسكريه يؤدي الى توقف الملاحه في خليل
والاعتبار الثاني والثالث سوف يؤدي الى
ارتفاع كبير جدا في اسعار النفط الامر الا
يؤثر على كامل الاقتصاد العالمي بالطبع
للاقتصاد الامريكي الاعتبار الثاني اللي
هو
او السبب الثالث اللي بيخلي
او اكبر واعلى الغاء العمليه العسكريه
والتوقيت
توجيه ضربه عسكريه في الاراضي الان اللي
ممكن تتسع الى حرب يتعارض مع امرين مهمين
امر محل وهو استعداده للتمهيد للترشح
لولايه ثانيه في الولايات المتحده صحيح ان
بعض الرؤساء الامريكان احيانا
بحصوله على شعبيه اكثر من خلال عمليات
عسكريه خارجيه
عمليه عسكريه لهدف السهل ومحدود تؤدي الى
يعني حشد الراي العام الداخلي
والمعارضه حول الرئيس الامريكي لكن مش حرب
مفتوحه
غير مامون العواقب او عدو يعتبر عاد قوى
وبالتالي لا يتعارض مع اجندته واعتباراته
الداخليه تم مرشح للرئاسه للفتره القادمه
اثنين على مستوى منطقه الشرق الاوسط هو
كان بيستعد الاطلاق او الكشف عن تفاصيل
خطه السلام
المعروفه بصفقه القرن وليس من المناسب
ابدا انك تحاول تمرر هذه الصفقه او هذه
الخطه وفي نفس الوقت تورط في عمليه عسكريه
تشمل كل دول المنطقه او قد تسعى الى كل
دول ال
الاسدي لكل الاسباب دونالد ترامب لم يكن
راغبا في التورط في عمليه عسكريه ضد ايران
لكن هو كان يفضل ومازال افضل ضرب ايران
بوسائل اخرى انه يستهدفها بوسائل اخرى غير
الوسائل العسكريه وسائل تلحق كبير بايران
ولا تولت الولايات المتحده في حرب مباشره
او اي خسائر في الارواح او تكاليف كبيره
يعني ماليه اول
الاول اشكال هذه الحرب وما يعرف بحرب كل
الرابع اللي ممكن نتكلم عنها في حلقه
مفصله لكن خلاصتها ان
الاشتباك في حرب مباشره مع القوات المسلحه
الايرانيه فيها المغامره ومكلفه
فيها يعني عنصر مخاطره زي ما شرحت
الحضارات يبقى الافضل اتكلم بالمواجهه
المباشره واستهدف العنصر الثاني لاي بلد
اي بلد هنا عنصريه الشعب والقوات المسلحه
بلاش الاشتباك المباشر مع القوات المسلحه
واوجه حربه على الشعب بمعنى انه انا
استخدم كل الوسائل اللي استطيع اننا اه
استخدمها عشان اوصل الرساله واحده للشعب
ان اليوم سيء وغدا سوف يكون اسوا وان لا
مستقبل لكم اذا تمسكت سياستكم ال مناوئه
للولايات المتحده وان حكومتكم لن تقدم الا
لمزيد من المدا عم والتوتر
والاجهاد والمستقبل السيد وبالتالي الافضل
من الى دكتور علي دولتك مو حكومتكم بدل ما
احنا بدل ما انت وتعاون اكثر واحد بدهم
يعملوا الحكايه من سنوات طويله جدا اثنين
انهم يعيشوا الحرب بالفعل ولكن حروب
بوسائل عسكريه اخرى منها الحرب مرور او
الحروب السيبرانيه زي ما بيقولوا باللغه
العربيه اللي هي الحروب تكنولوجيا اللي
بحاول الاشياء اللي فيها القدرات العسكريه
الايرانيه
واح يدها بدون تكلفه تذكر وهم شنوا عمليه
من هذا النوع في ثلاثه وعشرين يونيو
اسقاط الطائره الامريكيه بحوالي ثلاثه
ايام العمليه استهدفت شل
كل منصات اطلاق الصواريخ الايرانيه
وايران
اعلنت ان هذه العمليه فشلت سواء العمليه
ناجحه او فشلت لكن المساله مستمره
جديده بيعملوا القصه دي على الاقل من
الفين وعشره وفي الفين وعشره على سبيل
المثال شنو عمليه من هذا النوع
اجهزه الكمبيوتر الايرانيه اللي مسؤوله عن
تخصيب اليورانيوم في برنامجها النووي
الشكل الثالث اللي تستخدمها الولايات
المتحده في حربها المباشره على ايران هي
طبعا وهي الاهميه الحرب الاقتصاديه الحرب
الاقتصاديه اللي زوجها الرئيس الامريكي ب
عقوبات اضافيه شملت لاول مره وزير
خارجيتها والمرشد الاعلى للثوره الايرانيه
هل الحرب الاقتصاديه مجديه ادت الى الحاق
اضرار عنيفه جدا بالاقتصاد الايراني بحيث
انه بات مخلوق ومعزوله عن العالم هو
يستهدف ايه من استخدام الحروب اللي هي
الرابع او الحروب السيطره عليها او الحرب
الاقتصاديه
سيد ما اقول لحضرتك انه لا يتورط في حرب
مباشره مكلفه وفي نفس الوقت ممارسه ضغوط
عنيفه جدا على الايرانيين
واذا هذه الضغوط وصلت لحد لا يحتمل عند
الايرانيين يفوز الرئيس الامريكي باحدى
الحسنيين الحسن الاولى انه يقبل
الايرانيين على الحضور او المجيء الى
مائده المفاوضات ولما يقولوا مائده
المفاوضات ابتدى يفهم على كل المطالب التي
تدعم
حلفائه في المنطقه وتحديدا بعض دول الخليج
واسرائيل
اولا اذا فشلت هذه
يعني اذا فشل اذا فشل هذا المسار ورفض
الايرانيون ان ياتوا كما هو حادث الان
يبقى في الحاله هذه الضغوط المستمره سوف
تؤدي الى ارتكاب اخطاء الى ايران ارتكاب
ايران الى اخطاء اخطاء من نوعيه
تحت الضغط يقوموا بعمليات تؤدي الى تعطيل
الملاحه البحريه في خليج على سبيل المثال
بشك يستعد كل دول العالم ضدهم او خطا ثاني
اللي هو التهديد وتنفيذ الخروج من الاتفاق
النووي الامر الذي ادى الى استعداد دول
اوروبا الرافضه لشن حرب على ايران فاذا
خرجت من الاتفاق النووي الدول الاوروبيه
يكون عندها مبرر انهى تصطف الى جانب
الولايات المتحده
وفي الحاله دي الولايات المتحده سوف تجد
الشركاء اللي هي مش ل اياهم دلوقتي على شن
حرب كبيره على ايران
والا تفسر انه يدعوها الى المفاوضات
ويلحق وفي نفس الوقت هو بيفرض عقوبات على
وزير خارجيتها اللي هو المفروض انه رايح
كي عليهم عشان نتفاوض معهم انه يفرض
عقوبات على المرشد الاعلى بك لما له من
اهميه دينيه وسياسيه في ايران معناها انه
اما انه يعني غير جاده في المفاوضات وعاوز
الايرانيين يرتكبوا خطا
يستغلها في توسيع دائره
اعداءهم في العالم وبالتالي يستطيع ان يشن
لاحقا حرب موسعا مع عدد كبير من الحلفاء
يختار وتوقيتها وحجمها
في الشكل الذي
اشكركم والى لقاء اخر ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]